here now with reaction house Judiciary
Committee chairman Jim Jordan house
oversight committee chairman James Comer
Jim Jordan let me go so let me
understand the testimony of of John
Durham today uh they never corroborated
a single thing on in Hillary's dirty
dossier but they used it ever to get
four Visa applications approved Andrew
McCabe said without the dossier they
never would have got any of them
approved
um and then of course there was no
reason at all to even open operation
Crossfire hurricane right and then we
had lion corrupt go ahead
never corroborated anything ever in the
dossier opened the investigation without
the proper predicate without probable
cause but I think the most compelling
thing that that happened was in the
summer of 2016 our government gets
intelligence that says this all was a
made-up story from the Clinton campaign
she approved it to take the pressure off
of her email Scandal that is so credible
that John Brennan briefs President Obama
vice president by an attorney general
Lynch and director Comey and then he
puts it into a memo called a referral
memorandum that memo was given to Comey
and Peter strzok they failed to take it
to the fisa court they failed to show it
to the lawyers putting together that
fisa application and worse yet they
don't give it to the agents working the
crossfire hurricane case and then when
Mr Durham does his investigation he's
talking with one of those agents in the
reported supervisory agent number one he
tells that agent here's the referral
memo did you see this he didn't see it
he lets him read it when the guy gets
done reading it he gets him emotional he
gets up leaves the room with his lawyer
comes back in sits down I mean he says I
should have had this information this
could have changed everything but Jim
Comey and Peter strzok kept it from him
a good Agent trying to do his job I mean
he was ticked off that he didn't have it
so I think this just underscores why we
have to this Congress fundamentally
change the fisa process it's up for
reauthorization by December 31st we
Republicans in the house are committed
to not letting that thing get
reauthorized in its current form and
making dramatic changes to it why didn't
John Durham get this out before the
election in 2020 that's question number
one and question number two uh Jim
Jordan I would guarantee you that if I
or anybody in this wonderful audience we
have here tonight if they lied before a
fisa court judge and gave them
information that they knew wasn't
corroborated the FBI offered Christopher
Steele over a million dollars to
corroborate any part of that dossier
before they filed the first pfiza
application he couldn't corroborate a
thing but they used it anyway it says at
the top of that fisa application correct
me if I'm wrong verified that means they
purposely willfully lied to fisa court
judges not once but four times three of
those fisa warrants signed by James
Comey himself
to spy on American citizens who were
associated with the presidential
campaign that's what they did that's why
it's so egregious I think John Durham
did a good job I think he did as good a
job as he could have done he tried to
interview certain people the source of
this whole
why did why didn't he get Tommy and
struck in there and Paige in there yeah
I think he tried when you go you got you
got to be careful when you go to the
grand jury certain rules you have to
follow it was tough but he tried to go
to the source of all this this guy named
mifsid in Italy he traveled clear to
Italy tried to find him I wish he would
have because that's where this whole
thing started but you're right Sean
sixty percent of the American people
think there's a double standard at the
FBI they think that because there is and
that's what has to change and it starts
with the appropriation process with
House Republicans and making sure fisa
doesn't get reauthorized in its current
form three years too late and too little
and too few indictments but uh it was
important what you revealed to the
country today thank you for doing that
uh Jim Coleman
let me ask you
so
we have the attorney uh uh for somebody
on tonight that got 46 months in jail
for not putting the truth on his gun
application what do you make of the
sweetheart deal and what did you make of
the Revelation by Hunter's own attorney
that they never asked about the hunter
Biden laptop that we know as crimes on
it isn't that true
yeah well first of all times it's a it's
a double standard uh anyone else in
America whose last name isn't Biden or
Clinton would have gone to jail and they
would have gone to jail three or four
years ago for what Hunter Biden did the
FBI the doj the IRS none of those
government agencies have looked into
anything with the bidens my sources tell
me that they were told to stand down at
all of these agencies they hoped to run
out the statute of limitations and they
hope that the Democrats would retain
control of the House of Representatives
in the Senate so this would just go away
they knew they had the media that would
get their backs and they never thought
that there would be a scenario where
there would be a republican committee
like the house oversight committee which
Jim Jordan's on that would be uncovering
all of the fraud that I believe the FBI
many in the IRS and and many of the doj
knew the bidens were doing all along all
right now I think think Americans want
to know tonight that this sweetheart
deal that Biden's doj gave his son
hunter that will not have any jail time
I think Americans want to know that
you're going to follow every single dime
find out how much money this family did
in business with all these foreign
countries and entities how much money
they made in profit and whether or not
Joe benefited from it and whether or not
actions were taken as is suggested in
that 1023 form actions taken by then
Vice President Joe Biden in exchange for
family money
yes sir what what happened yesterday
with the plea deal that will not affect
our investigation one bit this was in
December when we announced investigation
and is today in June an investigation of
Joe Biden We are following the money
we've already followed many bank
accounts uh many Bank transfers Bank
wires that that happen from China to the
Biden family through the shell companies
that were then laundered down to the
Biden family members the same thing
happened in Romania we're starting to
get bank records now from Ukraine and
Russia and there are three or four other
countries you mentioned some earlier
Sean that were desperately working to
get those bank records to find those
shell accounts and we're going to expose
the bidens for the schemes that they
committed and we are going to also bring
people in very soon that will be under
deposition that are going to tell the
story of what role Joe Biden played in
this Joe Biden was integrally involved
he was a center central figure in the
whole Biden family influence peddling
schemes and unfortunately for Joe Biden
the Republican majority in the house
will continue to expose the truth and
present the facts to the American people
and to the media even though most media
Outlets aren't reporting it we're going
to continue to expose the truth and I
think that there will be a time very
soon when this family will finally be
held accountable and you believe you
already have identified nine Biden
family members that have gotten paid you
have identified numerous shell
corporations that didn't have any real
business purpose except to funnel money
do you believe that 1023 form is correct
that Joe Biden took actions in exchange
for money for millions of dollars for
him and Hunter and where is that money
where did that money go I do believe
that it's very likely that happened
because what we saw in Romania was
consistent with what the oligarch from
Ukraine alleged we saw soon after Joe
Biden left Romania with foreign aid then
the family less than two weeks later
started getting wires from Romanian
foreign Nationals and it wasn't just one
payment of a million dollars it was
several payments that were wired through
shell companies remember in the 1023
form that the FBI claimed didn't even
exist three weeks ago it said that the
oligarch was joking and was proud of the
fact that no one would ever find this
money because of the way that they
laundered the money through various
Banks we found the infrastructure where
the binds were laundering money through
shell companies and I believe that it's
consistent with what the oligarch
alleged and the FBI form I'll say this
both you and Jim Jordan if it's not for
you we'll never get the truth about the
bidens because you're not going to get
it from Chris Ray you're not going to
get it from his FBI you're not going to
get it from this weaponized doj and and
frankly Garland and Ray need to go and
we're going to be counting on you to get
to the truth both of you thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else